all right hey palsies my name is cody
and i'm a helpster that means a monster
who helps and because i love love love
to help so much i'm making these videos
called helpsters
help you
there are so many people helping us
right now and i wish there was a way we
could say thank you to all of them
well guess what there are so many ways
you could write a letter or send a card
or a drawing or you can make a video
like i'm doing right now
or you could sing them a song and you
could get some friends to help like
hey
group love hey you got your instruments
all ready to make some music
no no we don't
we thought we'd loop sounds to make
music instead right everybody yeah
yeah i
love that idea you know my friends and i
loop sounds all the time oh loop means
to do something again and again okay
everybody so when cody says so let's
loop our sounds yes please and then
please stop looping when christian and
hannah and i stopped singing got it
got it got it oh oh and everybody
watching at home feel free to clap along
huh okay start us off benjamin
[Music]
[Music]
and
kinds of work that would be difficult to
do on our own
[Music]
we need packages
we need medicine and care when we're not
feeling so
[Music]
cause that's what they do but don't
worry you can do something too sing a
song and say thank you
sing a song and say thank you thank you
health care workers sing a song and say
thank you thank you delivery people sing
a song and say thank you thank you
firefighters and police officers
[Music]
there are so many other people i want to
thank to like like like transportation
workers and
grocery workers and
teachers and janitors and volunteers and
well i guess what i'm really trying to
say is thank you to everyone who's
keeping us safe and happy and healthy oh
and a special thanks to all the kids who
are giving grown-ups a helping hand i am
so proud of you now if you'll excuse me
i'm gonna go see if there are even more
ways i can help and i hope you'll do the
same
bye
helpsters
help you